This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. As we go through life, other people often hold the keys to our success and happiness. In school, how your teachers think of you makes a difference in how they evaluate you. Do they see you as a serious scholar or a disinterested student? As you grow older, you might try to impress someone whom you see as a potential romantic partner. You want this person to like you, to date you. In the workplace, we jockey for status and opportunities. We might ask a boss for a raise or a promotion. How you come across to her will influence whether she says yes to you or tells you to take a hike.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔。在人生的旅途中，他人往往掌握着我们通往成功和幸福的钥匙。在学校里，老师对你的看法会影响他们对你的评价。他们认为你是认真的学者，还是对学习漠不关心的学生？随着年龄的增长，你可能会试图给那些你视为潜在恋爱对象的人留下好印象。你希望这个人喜欢你，跟你约会。在职场中，我们争夺地位和机遇。我们可能会要求老板加薪或晋升。你给老板留下的印象将决定她是会对你点头称是，还是叫你走人。
Countless books and reddit threads tell you how to navigate these waters. A YouTube influencer might tell you to play nice. A TikTok star might recommend playing hardball. Much of the advice you get will be contradicted by other advice you get. In recent years, social scientists have started to study how we can more effectively influence how others think of us. They've discovered both pitfalls and opportunities in the way we go about trying to influence the opinions of people. Unlike a lot of what you hear on YouTube and TikTok, these researchers are not just sharing their personal opinions,
无数的书籍和红迪网（Reddit）帖子都在教你如何应对这些局面。YouTube上的网红可能会告诉你为人要随和。TikTok上的明星可能会建议你态度强硬。你得到的很多建议往往会相互矛盾。近年来，社会科学家开始研究如何更有效地影响他人对我们的看法。他们发现在我们试图影响他人观点的过程中，既有陷阱，也有机遇。与你在YouTube和TikTok上听到的大多数内容不同，这些研究人员不仅仅是在分享个人观点，
their conclusions are guided by experimental evidence. The science of how to win friends and influence people, this week on Hidden Brain. Let's say you have a job interview. How do you carry yourself? You might wear a nice outfit, walk into the room with your shoulders back, and offer a firm handshake. Or imagine you run into a neighbor. You smile at them, make small talk, give a friendly wave.
他们的结论是以实验证据为指导的。《如何赢得朋友并影响他人》的科学原理，本周收听《隐藏的大脑》。假设你有一场求职面试。你如何展现自己？你可能会穿一身得体的衣服，昂首挺胸走进房间，并提供一个坚定的握手。或者想象一下你遇到了一个邻居。你对他们微笑着打招呼，闲聊几句，友善地挥挥手。
What about buying a car? Chances are you speak confidently to salesmen, so they offer you a good deal. Each of these is a small way we interact with other people. At the University of North Carolina, organizational psychologist Allison Fragale studies these interactions and how they shape what others think of us. Allison Fragale, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. So great to be here. Allison Fragale, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. So great to be here. Allison, I want to take you back to one of your early efforts to win friends and influence people.
买车呢？你很可能会自信地与销售人员交谈，这样他们就会给你一个好价钱。这些都是我们与他人互动的小方式。在北卡罗来纳大学，组织心理学家艾莉森·弗拉加莱（Allison Fragale）专门研究这些互动以及它们如何塑造他人对我们的看法。艾莉森·弗拉加莱，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。很高兴来到这里。艾莉森·弗拉加莱，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。很高兴来到这里。艾莉森，我想带你回到你早期赢得朋友和影响他人的尝试中去。
In your sophomore year of high school, you decided to run for a position on your student council. What was the position you wanted and how did it turn out? Not well. I lost. I had a position my freshman year, decided I was going to run again for sophomore year, felt pretty confident, and was really surprised and disappointed that I didn't win. So the fires of your political ambition continued to burn bright, and you decided to give it another shot the following year. Did you decide to do anything differently? I did. I was running for a junior vice president position. And because I thought I had been a little bit complacent in my sophomore year, I put a lot of work position. And because I thought I had been a little bit complacent
在你高二那年，你决定竞选学生会的一个职位。你当时想要的是什么职位？结果怎么样？不太好。我落选了。我高一时当过一个职位，决定在高二时再次参选，当时感觉挺有信心的，结果没当选，这让我感到非常意外和失望。所以你政治雄心的火苗依然在熊熊燃烧，你决定第二年再试一次。你决定做些什么改变吗？是的。我当时在竞选高三副主席的职位。因为我觉得自己在高二时有点过于自满，所以我在这场演讲上花了很多心思。职位。并且因为我觉得自己在高二时有点过于自满，
in my sophomore year, I put a lot of work into my speech. I thought this is, you know, it's high school. It's all won and lost in the quality of that speech and it's gotta promise great things. And it also importantly has to be funny. So I worked and my mom tried to help me write a good speech. What did she come up with? Or what did you come up with together? Well, when I told her I was running for vice president, she thought about the presidency
我在这场演讲上花了很多心思。我想，你知道的，这只是高中。一切的胜负都取决于演讲的质量，而且它必须承诺美好的事物。同样重要的是，它必须很有趣。所以我努力了，我妈妈也试图帮我写一篇好演讲。她想出了什么？或者你们一起想出了什么？嗯，当我告诉她我要竞选副主席时，她想到了主席的职位，
and said, what does the vice president even do except wait around for the president to die? And I said, maybe that can go in the speech. So I put in there something that seemed a lot funnier in high school, but it did land well, which was that I was well prepared to step in, in the event of the untimely death of our president. As I said, we were too young at that point to really have thought about, you know, our death and mortality. But people thought it was funny. So I thought I had a great joke. I'm well known. I'm liked. I'm going to win this.
然后说：“副主席除了等主席死掉之外，还能做什么呢？”我说：“也许这句话可以写进演讲里。”于是我加了一句在当时的高中看来好笑得多、但效果确实不错的话——我说我已做好充分准备，在我们主席不幸离世的情况下接替他的职务。正如我所说，我们当时太年轻，根本不会去考虑死亡和生命的有限性。但大家觉得挺搞笑的。所以我当时觉得我讲了一个绝妙的笑话。我很有名。大家都很喜欢我。我赢定了。
Alison thought she had the election sewn up, but like countless politicos before her, she was in for a shock. I do remember a friend of mine who I recently reconnected with, she was running unopposed in the same election, so she knew that she was going to have a position and she was part of counting the votes. And I very much remember her coming into the student lounge after the speeches with the saddest look on her face, telling me everything I needed to know that I did not win.
艾莉森本以为胜券在握，但就像她之前的无数政客一样，她即将迎来一个打击。我还记得我最近重新联系上的一位朋友，她在同一次选举中是无竞争对手参选，所以她知道自己肯定能当选，而且她还参与了计票工作。我清楚地记得，演讲结束后，她脸上带着极其悲伤的表情走进学生休息室，这告诉我一切我需要知道的事——我落选了。
She told me I had lost by a few votes, to whom I no longer remember, but my attempt was a failure. So I understand you were quite upset when you didn't win this race and your mother gave you some advice. What did she tell you, Allison? She told me what mothers everywhere say and what I now repeat to my own kids. She said, don't worry about what other people think of you. It's the kind of thing that all moms say it and no kids actually ever feel one bit better about it. But I think that messaging was given to me
她告诉我，我以微弱票数落选了，至于输给了谁我已记不清，但我的尝试失败了。我听说你当时落选时非常难过，你母亲给了你一些建议。她对你说了什么，艾莉森？她对我说出了天下母亲都会说的话，而现在我也同样会对我的孩子们说。她说：“不要在意别人怎么看你。”这是所有妈妈都会说的话，而没有哪个孩子会因此真的感到哪怕一丝轻松。但我认为，这种信息在我人生中
at many different times of disappointment in my life. And as a parent, I get it. You feel so bad for your kid when they're suffering and all you can tell them is to try to detach from the expectations or the judgment of the world around you. So you were not successful at changing how your classmates thought of you, but many years later you found yourself navigating a different problem that was also related
许多不同的失望时刻都被传达过。作为父母，我能理解。当你的孩子遭受痛苦时，你心里会非常难过，而你唯一能告诉他们的，就是试着摆脱周围世界的期望或评判。所以你并没有成功改变同学们对你的看法，但多年后，你发现自己面临着另一个问题，它同样与
to how people think of you. It had to do with how you tell others where you went to grad school. Can you explain, Addison? Well, I've played introduction dodgeball for years and years that when you meet somebody and they ask for something about you like, where'd you go to college? Where'd you grow up? And I developed this habit of not liking to disclose where I went to school. So I went to Dartmouth College for undergrad, I went to Stanford to get my PhD, and when people would say things like, where'd you go? I would give these vague answers like,
人们如何看待你有关。这与你如何告诉别人你在哪读的研究生有关。你能解释一下吗，艾莉森？嗯，多年来我一直在玩介绍躲闪球游戏——当你遇到某人，他们问起你的个人情况，比如“你大学在哪里读的？”“你在哪长大的？”——我养成了一种习惯，不喜欢透露自己是在哪所学校上学的。我本科就读于达特茅斯学院，在斯坦福大学获得了博士学位，每当人们问起“你在哪读的？”时，我就会给出一些模糊的回答，比如，
oh in the Northeast, in New Hampshire, on the West Coast, and then they would have to pull it out of me. I remember sitting at a blackjack table in Las Vegas with a stranger asking me where I went to school and I didn't even want to tell this guy that I was never going to see again where I went. And finally, you know, I said I went to Stanford and then I immediately, he said, oh, that's very impressive. And then I immediately just went into downplaying it. Well, not really, you know, I, you know, I just, I applied on a whim. I had some story about how that no one should pay attention to that. And every time I would have to say where I went to school,
“哦，在东北部”、“在新罕布什尔州”、“在西海岸”，然后他们就得一点点从我嘴里套出来。我记得有一次在拉斯维加斯的二十一点赌桌旁，一个陌生人问我是在哪上学的，甚至连对这个我再也不会见到的人，我都不想告诉他我在哪上的学。最后，你知道的，我说我去了斯坦福，然后我立刻——他说：“哦，那太令人印象深刻了。”然后我立刻开始淡化这件事。“哦，其实也没什么，你知道的，我，你知道的，我只是随性申请的。”我编造了一些让大家觉得不值得关注的故事。每次我不得不说出我在哪所学校上学时，
I would almost choke on the words and avoid eye contact. So why do you think you have played dodgeball when it comes to this question? What do you think you're trying to hide from others? I feel really grateful and really privileged that I got to go to those institutions, but I never have been able to utter those words without thinking that I sound obnoxious and like a snob. And that's never my intention in any interaction
我都几乎如鲠在喉，并避开与人对视。那你觉得为什么在这个问题上你会玩起躲闪球游戏呢？你觉得你在试图向他人隐藏什么？对于能去那些顶尖院校就读，我感到非常感激且十分荣幸，但我从来无法在说出这些话的同时，不觉得自己听起来傲慢得像个势利小人。而我在任何互动中的初衷，
to make anyone feel bad. And so I developed this habit of just going to great lengths to disclose it and then only making situations more awkward when other people would press, it would then just come off as weird as why did I have to ask nine questions to get a basic fact out of you? And I do it, I will disclose it now, but it still makes me really uncomfortable. Yeah, I'm also wondering if it can communicate the wrong message and a message that you were not trying to communicate at all, which is, you know,
都绝不是想让任何人感到难过。因此我养成了这种习惯：不遗余力地避而不谈，而当别人追问时，反而把情况弄得更加尴尬，这看起来就很奇怪——为什么从你嘴里套出一个基本事实需要问九个问题？我还是会做这件事，现在我会透露，但这依然让我感到非常不自在。是的，我也在想，这会不会传达出错误的信号——一个你根本不想传达的信号，也就是，
that you at some level thought that you went to a better school than the other person asking you this question and you thought they would feel bad as a result of not having gone to such a good school and so you're trying to hide the fact that you went to an elite school in order to make them feel better. And in some ways, could you be communicating to them in some ways that you actually have a hierarchy of schools in mind and that you actually thought that you did go to a better school? I think that's very much true because now as we're talking this and I think when someone
你在某种程度上认为自己去的学校比问你这个问题的另一个人更好，你觉得对方会因为没有去过那么好的学校而感到难过，所以你试图隐瞒自己上过精英学校的事实，以此来让对方好受一些。在某种程度上，你是不是在向他们传递这样一种信息：你的心中其实存在着一种学校排名的等级制度，并且你真的认为自己读的是一所更好的学校？我觉得确实如此，因为现在当我们谈论这个时，而且我认为当有人
then first discloses to me, oh, I went to Harvard or I went to Yale or something, I am much more likely to feel comfortable disclosing in exchange. So I do think there's probably an underlying assumption that if I'm talking to somebody I know nothing about, chances are statistically, they didn't go to a school that was as highly ranked, and I wouldn't want to be in a situation where I was saying that I had done something that was better.
首先向我透露“哦，我去了哈佛”或者“我去了耶鲁”之类的时候，我反而更有可能感到舒适并同样向对方透露。所以我确实认为，这背后可能存在一种潜在的假设：如果我在和一个完全不了解的人说话，从统计学概率上讲，他们大概率没有去过排名那么靠前的学校，而我绝对不想陷入这样一种境遇：我在说自己做过某件更出色的事情。
Yeah, but of course, once they find out that you did go to Dartmouth and to Stanford, then they not only know that you went to Dartmouth and to Stanford But they know that you think that they might have thought that They might have looked inferior if you told them that you went to Dartmouth or Stanford It's not a winning strategy, but I just have come to see how many times I confronted it It makes me uncomfortable and I start playing dodgeball I confronted it, it makes me uncomfortable, and I start playing dodgeball.
是的，但当然，一旦他们发现你确实去过达特茅斯和斯坦福，他们不仅知道了你读过达特茅斯和斯坦福，而且他们还会知道——你认为他们可能会觉得如果告诉你他们去了达特茅斯或斯坦福，自己会显得低人一等。这不是一个制胜策略，但我只是逐渐看清了自己面对这种情况的次数有多少。这让我感到不舒服，于是我开始玩躲闪球。我面对它，这让我感到不舒服，于是我开始玩躲闪球。
So your stories reveal the potential errors we make and how we seek to influence what others think of us. I want to look at a couple of other examples before we get to the science of what has underlined these interactions. Early in your teaching career, Allison, you won a prestigious teaching award. What was this award, and how did winning make you feel?
所以，你的这些故事揭示了我们在试图影响他人对我们的看法时可能犯下的错误。在我们探讨这些互动背后的科学原理之前，我想看几个其他的例子。艾莉森，在你教学生涯的早期，你曾获得过一个声誉卓著的教学奖项。这是一个什么奖？获奖让你有什么感觉？
My second year as a professor, I won what's called the Weatherspoon teaching award. There are several of them at the University of North Carolina named for the wonderful benefactor who funded them. And I won the one for undergraduate teaching, which was the course I was teaching when I started at UNC. So I was in my second year and I won this prestigious award. So one person wins in every teaching category each year. Yeah, yeah. So this is a big deal because to win in your second year means that you really made a very strong impression in your first year. I did and I felt good about it, especially because I came into UNC. I had never taught a single day in my life because my graduate program didn't give me that opportunity. So I went from never
在我担任教授的第二年，我获得了所谓的韦瑟斯庞（Weatherspoon）教学奖。北卡罗来纳大学有几个这样的奖项，是以资助它们的慷慨捐赠者的名字命名的。我获得了本科教学奖，那正是我刚到北卡罗来纳大学时教授的课程。所以我在第二年就赢得了这个声誉卓著的奖项。所以每年每个教学类别只有一个人获奖。对，对。所以这是一件大事，因为能在第二年就获奖，意味着你在第一年确实留下了非常深刻的印象。我的确做到了，而且我对此感觉很好，尤其是因为我刚来到北卡罗来纳大学时，我这辈子从来没有教过哪怕一天的书，因为我的研究生项目没有给我提供这样的机会。所以我从第一年从未
teaching in year one to winning an award in year two. And I did feel very proud about it and I felt that I had actually earned it because I put a lot of my heart and effort into making that class really great. Allison continued to be a great teacher, But as the months unfolded, something strange happened. Year three, she didn't win another teaching award. Year four, same thing. Year five? I'd come off of winning one award, so I thought winning awards wasn't really that hard to do.
教过书，到第二年就赢得了奖项。我确实为此感到非常自豪，而且我觉得这是我应得的，因为我倾注了大量的心血和努力，才把那门课上得那么棒。艾莉森继续做着一名出色的老师，但随着时间的推移，几个月过去了，奇怪的事情发生了。第三年，她没有再赢得教学奖。第四年，同样如此。第五年呢？我刚赢得过一个奖项，所以我以为赢得奖项其实并不是什么难事。
And I started to think about, surely I'm going to get recognized at some point. They're going to run out of people to award. The school's only so big. If nothing else, the process of elimination. So, I wouldn't, I was always happy because the other people who would win were also amazing. So there was never any, I'm definitely a better teacher than that person because it's not true. But there was a part of me that always thought surely at some point I'm going to have to win because I do a really good job at this. So a senior colleague comes up to you at one point and makes an interesting suggestion. Tell me what the suggestion was and how you responded. Yeah, so my friend who's the chair of my area at the time comes into my office at the school,
我开始心想，我肯定在某个时刻会得到认可。他们总会把奖颁完的。学校就这么大。再怎么说，通过淘汰法也该轮到我了。所以，我不会，我总是很高兴，因为其他获奖的人也同样非常优秀。所以我从来没有产生过“我绝对比那个人教得好”的想法，因为事实并非如此。但我的内心深处总有一种想法，认为由于我把这项工作做得很好，在某个时刻我肯定会获奖。所以有一次，一位资深同事走到你面前，提出了一个有趣的建议。告诉我这个建议是什么，你是怎么回应的。嗯，当时担任我所在领域系主任的朋友来到我在学校的办公室，
shuts the doors of something bad is going to happen, but he says something very kind. He said, I had been teaching this required course. I was getting ready to ready to transition out of it, hand it over to someone else. And he said, you haven't won this award yet. And would you like me to put together a group of people to nominate you for the award, essentially to court nominations so that the the award committee would see not just one or two letters but ten or twelve letters just from students from faculty Etc and it was a very very kind nice offer coming from a place of respect I think for the work that I had done and did you jump at this opportunity? I Didn't I had the opposite reaction and I feel a little, I said absolutely not. And
关上门，感觉好像要发生什么坏事了，但他却说了一些非常温和的话。他说，我一直在教这门必修课。我正准备卸任，把它交接给其他人。他说，你还没拿过这个奖呢。你愿意让我组织一组人来提名你获得这个奖吗？本质上就是去争取提名，这样评奖委员会看到的就不只是一两封信，而是来自学生、教职员工等各方面的十到十二封信。这是一个非常非常善良、美好的提议，我认为这源于对我所做工作的尊重。那你抓住这个机会了吗？我没有。我有相反的反应，而且我感觉有点……我说“绝对不行”，并且
my facial expression led on some kind of offense. Like this was the most unethical, terrible idea I had ever heard of. And I don't know if this person who was asking me had done it, but I came to find out that lots of people did this. And I think in my reaction, it was almost offensive. Like this thing that many people were doing, which was creating these nominating committees, was so off-putting to me. So I said, no thanks, I'm not interested. I don't want to win it that way. So you wanted to win it in a way where you played no role whatsoever in engineering it. You just wanted to happen organically. I had this belief that that was how the people were winning was that
我的面部表情流露出某种被冒犯的情绪。就好像这是我听过的最不道德、最糟糕的主意。我不知道向我提出这个请求的人自己是否这样做过，但我后来发现，很多人都会这样做。而且我觉得我的反应，简直带着一种冒犯。就好像许多人都在做的事情——也就是创建这些提名委员会——让我感到无比反感。所以我说：“不，谢谢，我没兴趣。我不想以那种方式获奖。”所以你想以一种完全不需要你参与策划的方式获奖。你只想让它自然而然地发生。我当时有一种信念，认为其他人获奖的方式是：
students were just so moved by your teaching that they would just run forward at this nomination process in mass and write these glowing letters and the committee would read letter after letter of grateful student and they would have no choice but to award you this. But that really wasn't how these things were actually happening. It was genuine and it was people saying, this person really deserves to win. So let's put together a strategic approach for helping show this person's great work. But it felt icky to me. Alison's experiences are hardly unique.
学生们只是被你的教学深深打动，以至于他们会在提名过程中自发地蜂拥而至，写下这些热情洋溢的信件，然后委员会会阅读一封又一封来自感激的学生的信，他们将别无选择，只能把奖颁给你。但事情实际发生的经过并非如此。这其实是真诚的，是人们在说：“这个人真的配得上获奖。所以让我们制定一个战略方法来帮助展现这个人的优秀工作。”但这让我觉得很恶心。艾莉森的经历绝非个例。
When it comes to showcasing our achievements or telling other people about our accomplishments, we often do one of two things. Sometimes we come across as boastful. Other times we are so afraid about coming across as boastful that we hide our achievements under a rock. We expect the world to discover our genius and come knocking on our door with accolades. In time, after Alison became a researcher who studies how people win and lose respect, she realized not just that both strategies were flawed, but why they were flawed.
当需要展示我们的成就或向他人讲述我们的功绩时，我们通常会做两件事中的一件。有时我们会显得自吹自擂。而另一些时候，我们又极度害怕显得自吹自擂，以至于把我们的成就藏在岩石底下。我们期待世界能发现我们的天才，并带着赞誉来敲响我们的门。后来，当艾莉森成为了一名专门研究人们如何赢得和失去尊重的研究人员时，她不仅意识到这两种策略都有缺陷，还弄明白了它们为什么有缺陷。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. In one of Aesop's fables, a donkey finds the skin of a lion left in the forest by a hunter. The donkey decides to try it on. He hides in a thicket and as various animals walk by, he jumps out and scares them out of their wits. The scam works perfectly until the donkey breaks out in laughter at his frightened victims. His braes echo through the forest. A fox walking by gives him some advice.
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔。在伊索寓言中，一头驴子在森林里发现了一张猎人留下的狮子皮。驴子决定试穿一下。它躲进灌木丛里，当各种动物走过时，它突然跳出来，把它们吓得魂飞魄散。这个恶作剧进行得非常完美，直到驴子看到被吓坏的受害者时忍不住大笑起来。它的驴叫声在森林里回荡。一只路过的狐狸给了它一些建议。
If you had kept your mouth shut, you might have frightened me too. But you gave yourself away with that silly brae. How do you want others to see you? As a powerful lion? A generous friend? A confident colleague? Organizational psychologist Alison Fregale says like that donkey in the story, most of us undermine our own efforts to get people to see us the way we want to be seen.
如果你一直闭紧嘴巴，你也许也能把我吓退。但你那愚蠢的叫声暴露了你。你希望别人怎么看你？是一头威风凛凛的狮子？一个慷慨的朋友？还是一个自信的同事？组织心理学家艾莉森·弗拉加莱说，就像故事里的那头驴一样，我们大多数人都破坏了自己让别人按我们期望的方式来看待我们的努力。
Alison, I want to go back to the advice your mother gave you in high school when you lost that election for vice president. She told you not to worry about what other people thought of you. Was it good advice? It's kind, but if it's taken the way most people take it, it's not good advice because it tells us that we should ignore or stop trying to influence how other people see us. And I do think that is bad advice. And do you think it's bad advice
艾莉森，我想回到你高中落选副主席时你母亲给你的建议。她告诉你不要在意别人怎么看你。这是一个好建议吗？它的心意是好的，但如果按照大多数人的理解方式去接受它，这就不是一个好建议，因为它告诉我们应该忽视或者停止试图影响别人如何看待我们。而我认为这是一个糟糕的建议。你认为这是一个糟糕的建议是因为
because that's an impossibility for us that we are a social species, that other people's opinions of us do matter and asking us to ignore those opinions in some ways, goes against every part of our social being? Exactly, because when we think about how many impressions we carry of other people, so if we use ourselves, those impressions guide our behavior. And so when you are negotiating with somebody, if you don't trust that person, if you don't like that person, the
这是我们无法做到的一件事，我们是社会性动物，别人对我们的看法确实很重要，而要求我们忽视这些看法，在某种程度上违背了我们社会属性的每一个部分？正是如此，因为当我们想到我们脑海中承载着多少对其他人的印象时——如果我们用自己来做比喻——这些印象会指导我们的行为。因此，当你与某人谈判时，如果你不信任那个人，如果你不喜欢那个人，
thoughts in your head about that other person have a great impact on whether or not you're going to be able to reach an agreement and whether or not it's going to be good. And so if we get into this logic, which I understand it's a lore, is we don't have to care about what other people think or don't worry about what other people think, it can lead us to some really suboptimal problematic strategies that don't serve us well, and then we're left confused as to why I didn't get a good outcome. So you've become interested in studying something that many people would like to pretend doesn't matter. You study status. What do you mean by status, Allison? The way we study it is the respect and regard that others have for us. So my status is how much other people respect and regard me. Your status is how much other people respect and regard you.
你脑海中关于那个人的想法，会对你是否能够达成协议以及协议是否会好产生巨大影响。如果我们陷入这种逻辑——我能理解它的吸引力所在——即“我们不必在意别人怎么想”或者“不要担心别人怎么想”，它可能会引导我们走向一些非常次优的、有问题的策略，这些策略对我们毫无帮助，然后我们就会对“为什么我没有得到一个好结果”感到困惑。所以你开始对研究一件许多人愿意假装它并不重要的事情感兴趣。你研究的是地位。艾莉森，你所说的地位是什么意思？我们研究它的方式是其他人对我们的尊重和敬重。所以我的地位是其他人对我的尊重和敬重程度。你的地位是其他人对你的尊重和敬重程度。
So when people say they don't care about status or that status doesn't matter, you sometimes cite the words of a 16th century English playwright. What did Christopher Marlowe have to say about status? He allegedly said, and it turns out that it's very problematic to quote long dead people because there's very little internet record of it, but allegedly he said we control 50% of a relationship, we influence 100% of it. And I think that's really wise advice, which is when it comes to status, it exists only in other people's minds, but its effects are very real and significant. And we can influence it. We cannot guarantee that another human being will give us respect and regard,
所以当人们说他们不在乎地位，或者地位不重要时，你有时会引用一位16世纪英国剧作家的话。克里斯托弗·马洛（Christopher Marlowe）对地位有什么看法？据说他说过——事实证明，引用早已去世的人的话是非常有问题的，因为互联网上几乎没有关于它的记录——但据说他说过，我们控制一段关系的50%，我们影响它的100%。我认为这是一个非常明智的建议，也就是说，就地位而言，它仅存在于他人的头脑中，但其影响却是非常真实和巨大的。而且我们可以影响它。我们不能保证另一个人会给予我们尊重和敬重，
but we can do things that make it more likely that that will be the case. So let's look at some of the ways that can make it more or less likely that we can change how other people think of us. One way we try to protect our status is by demonstrating that we are smart and competent people. But the way we do this often doesn't communicate what we think it communicates. I understand this once happened to you in a conversation you had with an employee of yours, your nanny? Yeah, so I um
但我们可以做一些事情，让这种情况更有可能发生。让我们来看看有哪些方法可以或多或少地改变别人对我们的看法。我们试图保护地位的方法之一，是证明自己是聪明能干的人。但我们这样做的方式，往往并没有传达出我们以为自己传达的信息。据我所知，这曾经在你与你的一个员工——你的保姆——的一次对话中发生过？是的，所以我……
love to be correct or more accurately I should say I find it really hard to be told that I've done something incorrectly. I've made a mistake because I feel like I do work so hard to try to get all the things done and do all the right things. And so I was on the phone with my nanny. I was on the speakerphone. My oldest child, who's 15, is in the car. And I'm leaving on a 6 a.m. flight the next morning. And I said something like, you're gonna be here at 6 45 in the morning to take the kids to school. And she said, I figured that might be the case because I saw it on your calendar that you were leaving. Yes, I can be there. And I said, what do you mean you figured it might be the case? We talked about it and you said that you were
我喜欢自己是正确的，或者更准确地说，我应该说，当别人指出我做错了某事时，我发现自己很难接受。我犯了一个错误，因为我觉得自己为了把所有事情做好、做所有正确的事情，真的付出了巨大的努力。所以当时我在跟保姆通电话。我开着免提。我15岁的大儿子在车里。第二天早上我将赶一趟早上6点的航班。我说了一些类似这样的话：“你明天早上6点45分要来这里带孩子们去学校。”她说：“我想可能是这样，因为我在你的日历上看到了你要离开的日程。是的，我可以去。”我说：“你什么意思叫‘你觉得可能是这样’？我们之前讨论过，你说过你
going to come. And she said, I don't remember that. And to me, my first thought was, and I said, I said this to her, I said, it's really important to me that you know that I don't just leave town and assume that you're going to come in the middle of the night. I would not have done that to you without telling you. I really feel like I told you." She said, I don't remember, but she said, it doesn't matter. Either way, I'm available to do it. So there was no problem. She was coming. She didn't seem aggravated. We've worked together for years. But to me, the idea that I was not correct, that I had done something like this was so disturbing that I pulled the car over on the
会来的。”她说：“我不记得了。”对我而言，我的第一反应是——我对她说——我说：“对我来说非常重要的一点是，你知道我不会就这么离开城镇，然后还假设你会大半夜赶来。我不会在不告诉你的情况下对你做出这种事。我真的觉得我告诉过你。”她说：“我不记得了，不过没关系。无论如何，我有空去做这件事。所以没有任何问题。她会来。她看起来并没有生气。我们已经合作多年了。但对我而言，我竟然不正确、我做了这样一件事的想法是如此令人不安，以至于我把车停在了
side of the road and my son said, why are we stopping? I said, because I know I told her. So first thing I do is I search through my emails. I don't find it. So then I have to go through the text thread, which is incredibly inconvenient to search, but there I find it. A few thumb swipes up is me saying to her, can you comment 645 on whatever day it was Thursday? And she said, yes, not a problem. I'll put it in the calendar. And then I, that wasn't enough just to know that I had told her, I screenshot it and I texted it back to her and I said, I see, I did tell you this and I couldn't help myself even though as I tell it to you, like that doesn't look
路边，我的儿子说：“我们为什么要停车？”我说：“因为我知道我告诉过她了。”所以我要做的第一件事就是搜索我的电子邮件。我没找到。然后我不得不翻看短信串，搜索起来极为不便，但在那里我找到了。往上滑动几次大拇指，就是我对她说：“你能把评论定在6点45分，不管哪天，周四吗？”她说：“好的，没问题。我把它加到日历里。”然后我——仅仅知道我告诉过她还不够——我截了图，发短信回复她说：“你看，我确实告诉你了。”我忍不住这么做，尽管当我向你讲起这件事时，这在任何人看来都不是件好事，你会觉得“不，完全没必要这样做”，但我还是做了。所以，你的重点既在于显得能干，也在于证明你不是一个残酷的雇主。你在证明，事实上，你之前对她是很体贴的。这就是你想这么做的动机。但你觉得她会如何看待你发送给她的这条短信、这个截图呢？它基本上是在说：
very good on anyone and you're like, no, there was no need for that, but I did. So, I mean, you are focused both on looking competent, but also on demonstrating that you're not a cruel employer. You were demonstrating that, in fact, that you had been considerate of her earlier. That was your motivation in wanting to do this. But how do you think she saw this note that you sent her, this screenshot, which basically said,
“看，我们有过这段短信交流，而且确实同意在这一天来。”所以我并不确定。我没有问。我只是对整件事感到尴尬。但我认为，我本质上是在说：“我是对的，你是错的。”这就是这段沟通所传达的概念。所以当我在那种情况下时，我对那个人的好感并不会增加。我觉得自己刚刚被告知犯了一个错误，
look, we had this text exchange, and in fact agreed to come on this day. So I don't know for sure. I didn't ask. I just felt embarrassed by the whole thing. But I think that essentially what I was doing was saying I was right, you were wrong. That's the notion of the communication. So when I've been in that situation, I don't feel very endeared to the person. I feel like I've just been told I made a mistake
并且我感觉很糟糕。所以具有讽刺意味的是，是的，我向她传达“我在乎你，我不会做伤害你的事”的欲望，为了不被指责，我做了一件不必要的事情，而且绝对没有起到让我显得超级关怀和温暖的效果。是的，也就是说你的保姆心里想的肯定不是：“艾莉森是如此聪明、如此能干，而且总是在照顾我。”她心里想的肯定是：“为什么
and I feel bad about it. So the irony is yes, my desire to communicate to her, I care about you and I would not do something to hurt you. I then in a desire to not be accused of that, I did something that was unnecessary and certainly didn't have the effect of making me show up as super caring and warm. Yeah, I mean your nanny is not thinking, you know, Allison is so so smart and so competent and is always looking out for me. You know, she's thinking why does
艾莉森有一种强迫性的需求，非要向我证明她是正确的？”她可能真的是这么想的。我只是——再次重申——我不会去问她，因为我只是不想，我在心理上还没准备好听到答案。但正是如此，这开始显得很合乎逻辑，对吧？我被指责犯了一个错误。我必须纠正记录，证明我没有犯错。有一种非常自然的倾向会让人觉得：“哦，这很合理。这能挽救声誉。”但当你这么做时，我认为在某些情况下，绝对纠正记录可能真的很重要。
Allison have this obsessive need to prove to me that she's right? She might be thinking that. I'm just, again, I'm not going to ask her because I just don't, I'm not psychologically prepared to hear the answer. But exactly, you have this, it starts to seem logical, right? I've been accused of making a mistake. I must correct the record that I didn't make a mistake. There's a pretty natural tendency to say, oh, that makes sense. That's going to be reputation saving. But then when you do this, you, I think there are some situations where absolutely correcting the record could be really important.
而对我自己而言，我能从自己的行为中观察到的是，每当有人说“艾莉森，你可能错了”时，如果我真的觉得自己是对的，我就会有一种下意识的反应，必须把那个信息亮出来。我不仅能举出这个例子，还能举出其他例子——在这样做的过程中，我可能对自己的声誉造成了更多的损害。因为即使在你没有被指责的时候，你也不得不把那个信息塞进去，上面写着：
And for me, what I've been able to observe about my own behavior is I have a knee-jerk reaction to any time somebody says, Allison, you might be wrong if I really do think I'm right to have to put that information out there. And I can come up with not just this example, but others where in the act of doing that, I'm probably doing more harm to my reputation. Because even when you're not being accused, you've got to put in that information that says,
“为了让你知道，我把每件事都做对了。”我们试图给他人留下印象的另一种方式是。艾莉森，你最近写了一本书，你在书中写了一个非常有趣的献辞，你的编辑对它有一些想法。你写了什么？你的编辑又是怎么反馈的？艾莉森·弗兰泽尔 所以在我寄给编辑的手稿的第一个完整版本中，整本书都完成了，而献辞我是最后写的，而且我实际上对它相当骄傲。这就是我写的内容。我写道：“致那些在我既不可爱也算不上女汉子时不得不应付我的人，
just so you know, I was doing everything right. There's another way we try to make an impression on others. You recently wrote a book, Allison, and you wrote a very interesting dedication that your editor had some thoughts about. What did you write and what was your editor's feedback? Allison Frenzel So in the first full version of the manuscript that I sent to the editor, the whole thing's done, and the dedication, I wrote it last, and I was actually quite proud of it. This is what I wrote. I said, to those who've had to deal with me when I was neither likable nor badass,
尤其是我的丈夫和孩子们，他们经常承受我糟糕的一面却依然爱我；任何在高中时就认识我的人；以及那些不幸在我在喝完三杯咖啡之前就跟我说话的人。”这就是我的献辞。她的回应是：“不行。你不能这么做。这太妄自菲薄了。你写这本书是给不认识你的人看的。你不能在这本书的第二页就开始贬低自己。”所以我们刚才讨论过你如何不喜欢告诉别人
especially my husband and kids who often get the worst of me and love me anyway, anyone who knew me in high school, and those unfortunate enough to talk to me before I've had three cups of coffee. That was my dedication. And her response was, No. You cannot do this. It is way too self-deprecating. You are writing a book to people who do not know you. You cannot start off knocking yourself down on page two of this book. So we talked earlier about how you don't like to tell people
你上过达特茅斯和斯坦福，感觉这个例子和之前如出一辙。自贬全是为了显得谦逊，但人们往往并不那样看待我们的行为。艾莉森，当我们采取自贬的行为和言语时，会发生什么？嗯，当我没有提及我在哪里上学时，这是一种通过省略来进行的自贬，但这个献辞则是通过委员会（主动行为）。我实际上是在自愿向世界发布信息，说：“嘿，看我在各种事情上有多不擅长。”因此，自贬是一种幽默的形式。人们使用它的原因之一是为了搞笑。为了我们自己的声誉，幽默是一种很好的表现形式。它创造了社会凝聚力。幽默是一种聪明的行为。如果效果好，它会被认为更聪明。
you went to Dartmouth and Stanford, and it feels like this example is cut from the same cloth. Self-deprecation is all about wanting to come across as humble, but often people don't see our behavior that way. What happens when we act and talk in self-deprecating ways, Allison? Yeah, so when I failed to mention I'm where I went to school, it's self-deprecation of omission, but then this dedication is a commission. I'm actually putting information out there in the world voluntarily to say, hey, look at how I'm not good
所以你知道很多喜剧演员，他们整个职业生涯都在拿自己开玩笑。所以自贬可以是很幽默的。我想我之所以开始使用它，部分原因也是如此，因为我有幽默的风格，所以它符合我讲笑话的形式。其中的挑战在于——为什么它不如其他形式的幽默那么好——
at various things I am. And so self-deprecation is a form of humor. So one of the reasons that people use it is to be funny. And humor is a good behavior to put out in the world for our own reputation. It creates social cohesion. Humor is an intelligent act. If it lands well, it's considered smarter.
是因为人们会相信我们对自己说的话。我们是关于我们自己的专家。如果我告诉你我在某方面不太擅长，而我们也能看到这一点——当人们拿自己的外表开玩笑、拿自己的智力开玩笑时，人们就会认为他们更不搞笑、更好看程度更低、智力更低。所以我们才是专家。因此我们贬低自己。最终发生的结果是人们会说：
So you know a lot of comedians that have their whole careers are just poking fun of themselves. So self-deprecation can be humorous. And I think part of the reason I have come to use it is partly that, because I have a humorous style, and so it fits in with my forms of joke telling. The challenge with it is why it's not as good of a form of humor as other things,
“哦，你刚才自己说你在这方面不太擅长。那你肯定真的不太擅长。”所以，你从社会凝聚力中获得的任何好处——“哦，这很谦虚，这很好”——都会被你通过告诉别人你在你刚刚贬低自己的事情上不太能干或不熟练而受到相应的打击所抵消。还有一点就是，如果你擅长某事，如果你赢得了什么奖项，而你试图去安抚一个没有获奖的人——你在比赛中赢得了金牌，你试图通过说“哦，
is that people believe what we say about ourselves. We are the experts on ourselves. So if I tell you I'm not very good at something, and we see this, when people make fun of their looks, they make fun of their intelligence, people see them as less funny, as less good-looking, as less intelligent. So we're the experts. So we put ourselves down. What ends up happening is people say,
你知道奖牌不算什么”或者“赢并不是一切”来安抚没有站在领奖台上的人。在某种程度上，这并不能让你更受欢迎。那个没有赢得奖牌的人并不想听到奖牌不算什么这样的话。他们为没有赢得奖牌而感到难过，而你站在领奖台上告诉他们奖牌不算什么，就像一个有钱人对穷人说：“嗯，你知道的，别太担心。钱其实并不重要。”完全正确。因此，当人们的表现优于他人，然后他们试图淡化
oh, you just told me you're not very good at that. You must not be very good at it. So any benefit you might get from the social cohesion, oh, that's modest, that's nice, you're taking that corresponding hit by telling somebody you're not very competent or skilled in whatever you just put yourself down on. There's also the point that if you're good at something, if you've won something and you're trying to appease someone who has not won something, you've won the gold medal in a race and you're trying to appease the person who is not on the medal stand by saying, oh
自己的表现、高绩效时，这种做法的效果并不好，正如你所描述的那样。人们会说：“第一，我不相信你赢了。所以现在你是一个不诚实的人。”第二，“这并没有让我感觉好一点。所以我实际上并没有觉得与你建立联系，也没有感激你所做的事情。”我们都做过类似的事情来塑造别人对我们的看法。我们淡化自己的成就以显得谦逊。我们喋喋不休地阐述一个观点以显得聪明。有些特质是我们所有人都希望别人熟知的。
you know medals don't count or winning is not everything. In some ways that doesn't make you more liked. The person who hasn't won the medal doesn't want to be told that medals don't count. They're upset about not having won the medal and you as standing on the medal stand telling them that medals don't count is like the rich person telling the poor person, well, you know, don't really worry about it. Money doesn't really matter. That's exactly right. So when people have outperformed others and then they try to downplay
艾莉森的研究将这些特质归纳为两个截然不同的维度。嗯，这些是人际知觉的两个基本维度。不同的人叫它们不同的名字，但你会拥有一个“果断”维度。你能把事情做好吗？这将是果断、执着和能干。然后是“温暖”维度。除了你自己之外，你在乎其他人吗？这些与地位紧密相连。因此，当我们想到我们尊重的人时，我们尊重那些果断、能把任务做得又好又有效的人。并且我们尊重那些关心除自己以外他人的人。这是人际知觉的两个基本维度。
their performance, their high performance, it doesn't land well exactly in the way that you described. People say, I don't believe you one. So now you're, you know, you're not an honest person. And two, you're, it doesn't make me feel any better. So I don't actually feel connected to you or appreciate what you've done. We've all done things like this to shape how others perceive us. We downplay our accomplishments to seem humble. We belabor a point to appear intelligent. There are certain traits we all want to be known for.
我们关注人及其行为。我们沿着这两个维度对他们的行为进行编码，它们与地位的概念紧密相连。这其中可能会存在张力，因为你可以把它想象成一个二维空间。这其中可能会存在张力，因为你可以把它想象成一个二维空间。所以你可能在一个维度上得分很高，在另一个维度上得分很低。因此，你可以考虑做一些能为你赢得很多“果断、能干、决断”赞誉的事情，但被认为不够温暖。你也可以考虑一些情况，你可以做一些能帮你被视为非常友好、善良和讨人喜欢的事情，但往往是以牺牲你自己的能力和才干为代价的。
Allison's research puts these traits into two distinct categories. Yeah, so these are the two fundamental dimensions of person perception. Different people call them different names, but you're going to have a dimension of assertiveness. Can you get stuff done? It's going to be decisive and persistent and competent. And then a dimension of warmth. Do you care about people other than yourself? And these are very much linked to status. So when we think about people we respect, we respect people who are assertive and they can get tasks done well and effectively. And we respect people who care assertive and they can get tasks done well and effectively and we respect people who care about people other than themselves. Those are two fundamental dimensions of person perception.
这就是张力存在的地方，因为人们会发现自己身处两个象限中——我在生活中曾多次发现自己身处其中——你得到了其中一个，却失去了另一个。艾莉森在她的研究中发现，人们在果断和温暖这两个维度上的评分都可能很低。我们不尊重那些自私且缺乏自信的人。相比之下，每个人都尊重那些既果断又善良的人。历史上最受爱戴的领袖无一例外地将这两种品质结合在一起。这正是我们所有人都应该渴望栖息的象限。
We pay attention to people and what they're doing. We code their behavior along those those two dimensions and they're very much tied to this idea of status. And there can be attention because you can think about it as a two-dimensional space. And there can be a tension because you can think about it as a two dimensional space. So you can be high on one dimension, low on the other. So you can think about doing things that get you a lot of credit for being assertive and competent and decisive, but are seen as less warm. And you can think of situations where you can do things that are going to help you be seen as really nice and kind and likable, but often at the expense of your own competence and capabilities.
我们关注人以及他们在做什么。我们沿着这两个维度对他们的行为进行编码，这些维度与地位的概念紧密相连。由于你可以将其视为一个二维空间，因此可能会存在某种张力。由于你可以将其视为一个二维空间，因此也可能会存在某种张力。所以你可能在一个维度上很高，而在另一个维度上很低。因此，你可以考虑做一些事情，这些事情能为你赢得很多赞誉，让你显得自信、能干、果断，但被认为不够热情。你也可以想到这样一些情况：你所做的事情有助于让你被视为真正好心、善良且讨人喜欢，但通常代价是牺牲了你自己的能力和才华。
And so that's where the tension exists, is because there are two cells that people will find themselves, I've found myself in many, many times in life, where you're getting one but you're not getting the other. Allison has found in her research that people can be rated low on both assertiveness and on warmth. We don't respect people who are selfish and lack confidence. By contrast, everyone respects people who are seen as both assertive and kind. The most beloved leaders in history invariably combine both qualities. That's the quadrant we should all aspire to inhabit.
这就是张力存在的地方，因为人们会发现自己处于两个象限中——我在生活中也多次发现自己处于这种境地——你得到了其中一个，却失去了另一个。艾莉森在她的研究中发现，人们在自信和热情两个方面都可能获得很低的评分。我们不尊重那些自私且缺乏自信的人。相比之下，每个人都尊重那些既自信又善良的人。历史上最受爱戴的领导人总是兼具这两种品质。那是我们所有人都应该渴望入住的象限。
That's the quadrant we should all aspire to inhabit. But you can also be rated high on one dimension and low on the other. A ruthless hedge fund manager might be rated very high on competence and assertiveness, but be widely perceived as a jerk. Or you can have people who are seen as sweet, but ineffectual. To complicate matters, these two dimensions are sometimes at odds with one another. To be seen as assertive can make you less likely to be seen as warm and kind, especially if you're a woman. Women are stereotypically expected to be kind and sweet, so if a woman shows up in a meeting as very assertive, people unconsciously assume
这就是我们都应该向往的那种状态。但你也有可能在一个维度上得分很高，而在另一个维度上得分很低。一个冷酷无情的对冲基金经理可能在能力和自信上得分很高，但普遍被认为是个讨厌鬼。或者你也会看到一些人被认为是温和的，但却没什么作为。更复杂的是，这两个维度有时甚至是相互矛盾的。表现得自信可能会让你不那么容易被视为热情和善良，特别是如果你是一位女性的话。传统上，人们刻板地期望女性要善良甜美，因此如果一个女性在会议上表现得非常自信，人们就会下意识地认为
she cannot be nice. The researcher Jennifer Chapman once conducted a study looking at the teaching evaluations of male and female professors. I thought this was an amazing and depressing study as a middle-aged professor myself. What Jennifer and her colleagues did was they looked at longitudinal data of 15 years about of professors teaching evaluations. So they would have the same person like me who's taught for 20 years show up multiple times. They've taught years and years and years and they would compare each individual to themselves to say
她不可能是个好人。研究人员詹妮弗·查普曼曾做过一项研究，调查了男女教授的教学评估。作为一名中年教授，我认为这是一项既精彩又让人沮丧的研究。詹妮弗和她的同事们查阅了关于教授教学评估长达15年的纵向数据。所以他们会追踪像我这样教龄20年的同一个人，让他们多次出现。他们教了一年又一年，然后把每个人自身的数据进行对比，以得出
okay how did your evaluations change over time? And you might think oh evaluations are gonna get better for the people who succeed and stay, because they'll become more experienced professors. And then, I don't know, maybe at the end of their career, they tail off and they get worse. But what she and her colleagues found was this curve for female professors only. When they were younger, they would get high evaluations. As they went into middle age, their evaluations would drop. And as they got older, their evaluations would rise again. And that pattern was only observed for women, and it was not observed for the male faculty.
这样的结论：你的教学评估随时间发生了怎样的变化？你可能会想，哦，对于那些成功并留下来的人来说，评估结果会变得更好，因为他们会成为更有经验的教授。然后，我不知道，也许在他们职业生涯的末期，评估会有所下降，变得更糟。但她和同事们发现，这种曲线只存在于女教授身上。当她们年轻时，她们会获得很高的评价。当她们进入中年时，她们的评价就会下降。而随着年龄增长，她们的评价又会回升。这种规律只在女性身上观察到，而在男性教职员工身上则没有。
And they did some digging to find support for their theory, which relates to these dimensions of assertiveness and warmth, which is that the women who got the lowest teaching evaluations, which remember the women at the middle age, middle stage of their career, those women were perceived as the most assertive and the least warm. And that pattern of your assertive and cold was the unique perception of the middle-aged women in the faculty, but not for the men. And that research is very consistent with the work that I've done, which is that when are women gonna be at their highest power in their academic career? Generally at that midpoint. That's when you are
他们做了一些深入研究来寻找支持其理论的证据，这与自信和热情这两个维度有关。研究发现，获得最低教学评估的女性——也就是处于职业生涯中期的女性——被认为是最自信、最不热情的。这种“自信且冷漠”的模式是人们对教职员工中中年女性的独特看法，但对男性则不然。这项研究与我所做的工作非常一致，那就是女性在学术生涯中何时能达到最高权力？通常是在那个中点。也就是在你获得
tenured, you're serving in major administrative roles, etc. And so the story that I could tell from that study is, okay, if your power increases and your status doesn't, guess where you end up? In the low status powerholder cell, which is very assertive and very cold. And guess what? People don't like it and they don't treat you very well. And in this case, the mistreatment came in the form of the lower teaching evaluations, the lower performance evaluations that the female faculty got. When women acquire power in the workplace, a number of studies have found they are less likely to be perceived as warm and nice.
终身教职、担任重要行政职务等的时候。因此，我可以从那项研究中得出的故事是：好吧，如果你的权力增加了而地位没有增加，猜猜你会落入什么境地？你会落入低地位权力者的格子中，这非常自信且非常冷漠。你猜怎么着？人们不喜欢这样，对你的态度也不会很好。在这种情况下，这种虐待表现为女教职员工得到的较低的教学评估和较低的绩效评估。多项研究发现，当女性在职场中获得权力时，她们往往更不容易被认为热情和友善。
They are seen as powerful, but cruel. Allison says that combination makes us afraid. Because if someone's going to have control over me, I care a lot about the fact that they are going to do good things with it, not just to help me, but to make sure they're going to use it responsibly. If I don't respect somebody, I could be concerned, wait a second, you're going to have all this control and you're just going to mess it up. From friendships to job promotions, there are many consequences to how we go about interacting with others. Despite the great deal of time and effort we spend in managing how others see us, our
她们被视为强大但残忍。艾莉森说，这种组合让我们感到害怕。因为如果有人要对我有控制权，我非常在意他们是否会用它来做好事，不仅是为了帮助我，还要确保他们会负责任地使用它。如果我不尊重某个人，我可能会担心，等一下，你要掌握这么大的控制权，结果却把它搞砸了。从友谊到晋升，我们与他人互动的方式会带来很多后果。尽管我们在管理别人如何看待自己方面花费了大量的时间和精力，但我们的
efforts often backfire and people don't come away thinking of us as warm, competent and humble people. When we come back, better ways to win friends and influence people. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We spend a lot of time and effort trying to paint a certain picture of ourselves in other people's eyes.
努力往往会适得其反，人们最终并不会把我们看作热情、能力强和谦逊的人。稍后为您带来：赢得朋友和影响他人的更好方法。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们花费了大量的时间和精力，试图在别人眼中塑造一种特定的形象。
Organizational psychologist Alison Alison Fregail, is the author of Likeable Badass, How Women Get the Success They Deserve. She says that when we try to burnish our status, many of us use the wrong brush. Alison, we've been talking about status, how much we are respected, admired, and valued in the eyes of others,
组织心理学家艾莉森·弗雷盖尔是《讨人喜欢的女硬汉：女性如何获得应得的成功》一书的作者。她表示，当我们试图提升自己的地位时，许多人用了错误的方法。艾莉森，我们一直在谈论地位，即我们在他人眼中受到多少尊重、钦佩和重视，
and the wrong ways we often go about trying to build our status. A lot of people believe that you have this trade-off. Either I come across as assertive, or I come across as warm, or I come across as really likable, but then I sacrifice being seen as competent. You say that being successful involves eliminating this trade-off and coming across as both assertive and worn? That's right. So status is how much we're respected and regarded It's critically important to our life satisfaction and our career success. It's a fundamental human need
以及我们经常用错误的方法来试图建立我们的地位。很多人认为你必须做出这种权衡。要么我表现得很自信，要么我表现得很热情，要么我表现得非常讨人喜欢，但这样我就牺牲了被视为有能力的机会。你认为成功包括消除这种权衡，让自己同时表现出自信和热情吗？是的。所以地位就是我们受尊重和重视的程度，这对我们的生活满意度和职业成功至关重要。这是人类的基本需求，
Lacking status is physically and psychologically as damaging as living a life without friends. So building status is critical. How do we do it? We do it by showing up as assertive and warm. There's no doubt that for some people, women included, that getting to that quadrant feels elusive. But what I help people think about is it doesn't have to be elusive. And the first step in making it work and getting to that quadrant is not unintentionally doing things that are going to keep, put you somewhere else in that two dimensional space. And there's a phenomenon in psychology
缺乏地位在生理和心理上造成的损害，不亚于过着没有朋友的生活。因此，建立地位至关重要。我们该怎么做？我们通过展现自信和热情来做到这一点。毫无疑问，对某些人（包括女性）来说，进入那个象限似乎遥不可及。但我帮助人们思考的是，它其实并不遥不可及。让它发挥作用并进入那个象限的第一步，就是不要无意中做出那些会把你放在这个二维空间里其他地方的事情。心理学中有一个现象
known as compensatory impression management. And that's the tendency that human beings have, not just women, but human beings, that when you wanna show up as really strong on one of those dimensions, you do it in a bad way. You do it by making yourself look worse on the other. You want to show up as really assertive, you do it by showing up as less warm, which makes no sense. If you want to show up as assertive, you should show up as assertive.
被称为补偿性印象管理。这就是人类（不仅仅是女性，而是人类）的一种倾向：当你想要在其中一个维度上表现得非常强大时，你用了一种糟糕的方式。你通过让自己在另一个维度上看起来更糟来做到这一点。你想表现得非常自信，你通过表现得不够热情来做到这一点，这毫无意义。如果你想表现得自信，你就应该表现得自信。
That's not what people do. They say, I want to be really assertive, so I'm going to be less warm. I want to be really warm, so now I'm going to be less assertive. And that we compensate when we don't have to. So that quadrant, assertive and warm, it's possible to get there. It can be harder for some people, but we also make it harder on ourselves than it has to be by engaging in behaviors where we're deliberately only showcasing one and not the other when that is a false choice that doesn't have to be made. And so one of the things I help people think about when they're thinking about how can I show up in this assertive and warm cell is I say
人们可不这么做。他们说，我想表现得非常自信，所以我要表现得不够热情。我想表现得非常热情，所以现在我要表现得不够自信。我们在本不必妥协的时候进行了妥协。所以那个“自信且热情”的象限，是有可能达到的。对某些人来说可能更难，但我们也通过刻意只展现一面而不展现另一面的行为，把事情搞得比实际更难，而这其实是一个本不必做出的虚假选择。因此，当我帮助人们思考如何在这个“自信和热情”的格子中展现自我时，我告诉他们：
start with what who you naturally are and then add don't subtract. So if you have something that's very natural and authentic to you, even if it's more submissive, like your speech style, or maybe if it's not as friendly, like you're not a great smiler, OK, fine, it is what it is. But what are the things that you can add in that are going to get you more recognition on the other dimension where you think you might be lacking? So, Alison, you say that one of the ways we can try and get the best of both these worlds
从你原本的自然状态开始，做加法而不是减法。因此，如果你有一些非常自然和真实的东西，即使它更加顺从，比如你的说话风格，或者可能没有那么友好，比如你不太擅长微笑，好吧，没关系，事情就是这样。但是，有哪些事情是你可以添加进去的，从而在另一个你认为自己可能有所欠缺的维度上获得更多的认可呢？那么，艾莉森，你说我们可以尝试两全其美的其中一种方法
is to try and offer help to other people. What do you mean by this? Well, helping another person is definitely a warm act, it's a giving act, it's in service to somebody else. And if the help that you're offering also showcases that you are highly capable, then you can, in the act of of helping get credit for assertiveness as well. So if a friend needs a ride to the airport and I drive them, very warm thing to do, not particularly assertive, everybody else can drive to the airport as well. It doesn't help me
就是试着向其他人提供帮助。你这是什么意思？嗯，帮助别人绝对是一个温暖的举动，是一个奉献的举动，是为了服务他人。如果你提供的帮助同时也展示了你能力极高，那么你在帮助别人的同时也能获得自信的认可。所以，如果一个朋友需要搭车去机场而我开车送了他，这是一件非常温馨的事，但并不是特别自信，因为其他人也都可以开车去机场。这并不能帮我
show up as very unique or talented in any way. But if I have something that I do have a unique contribution, I always pride myself on being a good child care evaluator and hire. I could not do my work without the support of a lot of people in my life who take great care of my kids. And I feel over the years I've gotten really good at finding great people, setting up the expectations of the relationship very well, and creating a good environment for them to work in that has really been very successful.
以任何方式展现出我的独特或才华。但如果我有独特的贡献呢？我一直为自己是一个优秀的育儿评估员和雇主而感到自豪。如果没有生活中许多悉心照顾我孩子的支持者的帮助，我根本无法完成工作。我觉得这些年来，我在寻找优秀人才、明确双方关系期望以及为他们创造良好的工作环境方面变得非常擅长，这确实取得了极大的成功。
And when I see other people struggling, other parents, I'm quick to jump in and offer some advice or help because it's unique. It's something that I can offer that another person couldn't easily offer just at that moment. And so when we help in big or small ways that showcase our talents and give assistance to other people,
当我看到其他人（其他父母）在苦苦挣扎时，我会很快介入并提供一些建议或帮助，因为这是独特的。这是我能够提供而别人在那一刻不容易轻易提供的。因此，无论是以大还是小的方式提供帮助，只要能展示我们的才华并向他人提供援助，
that's an example of something that gets you credit for the assertiveness and credit for the warmth. Alison says another way to come across as both assertive and warm has to do with how we respond to praise and how we engage in self-promotion. A lot of information that people know about you, it ultimately originates with you. It's either interactions they've had with you, it's information you've put out into social media or on a website, something like that. And so we control a lot of the information that people get about us. So
这就是为你赢得自信和温暖认可的一个例子。艾莉森说，另一种既能表现得自信又能表现得热情的方法，与我们如何回应赞美以及如何进行自我宣传有关。人们知道的关于你的很多信息，最终都源于你自己。要么是他们与你的互动，要么是你发布到社交媒体或网站上的信息，诸如此类。因此，我们控制着人们获得的关于我们的许多信息。所以
we want to make that information certainly as positive as possible, on both dimensions, right, on assertive and warm. So there was some research that I thought was great that supported a technique that I had adopted myself years and years ago. And I call it brag and thank, and the psychologist who looked at it called it dual promotion,
我们当然希望这些信息尽可能积极，在两个维度上都如此，即自信和热情。因此，有一些研究我觉得很好，它支持了我多年前采用的一种技术。我称之为“吹嘘与感谢”，而研究它的心理学家称之为双重宣传，
or promoting self and other people at the same time. So when we promote ourselves and we say something good, we can imagine we're gonna get an assertiveness bump, but oh, maybe it's not so modest. So now we get a warm hit. Well, what if you also at the same time are offering sincere promotion and praise for somebody else who did something great in the process
或者同时宣传自己和他人。因此，当我们宣传自己并说出一些好事时，我们可以想象我们会获得自信心的提升，但哦，也许这显得不够谦虚。所以现在我们的热情度受到了打击。那么，如果在同一次过程中，你也对某个做得很好的其他人提供了真诚的宣传和赞美，会怎么样呢？
without diminishing yourself, deprecating what you did, but to say, hey, I had this great success, right? I got to achieve something. And special thanks go to people A, B, and C, without whom this could never happen. So you're telling your story, but you're at the same time saying something positive about other people.
这并不是贬低你自己，也不是贬低你所做的事情，而是说：“嘿，我取得了巨大的成功！我取得了一些成就。特别感谢A、B、C三位，没有他们，这一切都不可能发生。”所以你在讲述自己的故事，但与此同时你也在说其他人的好话。
That's an example of where you could use something that we've been told to do, self-promote, and tweak it, just add to it, in a way that's promoting about other people. That's an example of where you could use something that we've been told to do, self-promote, and tweak it, just add to it, in a way that's promoting the other people, you get more credit for the warmth. You talk about another idea called humor bragging that could help us in some ways resolve this tension between coming across as assertive
这就是一个例子：你可以把你被告知要做的事情——自我宣传——拿来并进行微调，只需在其中加入一些为他人进行宣传的内容，这样你就能获得更多关于热情的认可。你谈到了另一个名为“幽默吹嘘”的想法，它可以在某种程度上帮助我们解决表现得自信与表现得热情之间的这种张力。
and coming across as warm. What is humor bragging, Allison? So humor bragging is saying something positive about yourself while also using humor that is not self-deprecating. And this is one of my favorite findings that just recently came out, and I think it's brilliant. And what the research team found was that when people
什么是幽默吹嘘，艾莉森？所以，幽默吹嘘是指在说一些关于自己的积极事情的同时，使用不属于自我贬损的幽默。这是我最近发现的最喜欢的结论之一，我认为它非常绝妙。研究团队发现，当人们
in a context where you might need to self promote or brag, like searching for a job, where somebody said something positive and then added in something humorous, those people were granted more status and were more likely to be seen as viable candidates in a job selection process, for example, than for people who simply said something self promoting. What are the examples of self-promoting. One of the examples they had in the study was a job applicant who wrote a purely self-promoting statement that said, I'm highly motivated and detail-oriented sales representative with experience and a proven track record of people skills. I look forward to supporting your company's goals dedicatedly.
在可能需要自我宣传或吹嘘的情境中（例如寻找工作），如果有人说了积极的话然后加入了一些幽默元素，那么与那些单纯说一些自我宣传的话的人相比，这些人会被授予更高的地位，并且在例如工作挑选过程中更有可能被视为切实可行的候选人。自我宣传的例子有哪些？研究中的其中一个例子是一名求职者写了一份纯粹自我宣传的声明，上面写着：“我是一名高度积极且注重细节的销售代表，拥有相关经验以及出色的为人处世的人际交往记录。我期待着全力支持贵公司的目标。”
And then in another version offered a humor bragging statement. I'm a driven sales representative who's detail oriented and passionate about serving your company's goals. I have a proven track record of turning caffeine input into productivity output. More coffee you can provide the more output I will produce. And they found that when it was again, a positive statement combined with some humor, there was more interest in the candidate.
然后，在另一个版本中，他提供了一份带有幽默吹嘘的声明。“我是一名富有进取心的销售代表，注重细节，热衷于服务贵公司的目标。我有着将咖啡输入转化为生产力输出的丰富记录。你们能提供的咖啡越多，我产出的成果就越多。”他们发现，当积极的声明再次与一些幽默相结合时，人们对这位候选人的兴趣明显更高。
The candidate did a better job building their status and being able to be seen as a viable candidate for the job. That's what humor bragging is. So you've talked about how we sometimes hide our successes in order to come across as more warm and more likeable. So when we think our accomplishments will intimidate someone else, we sometimes mistakenly downplay them. You say that if someone is worried about coming across as intimidating, one way to buffer against that is to highlight their similarities with others. And you have a friend named Greg who
这位候选人在建立自己的地位以及让自己被视为这份工作的可行人选方面做得更好。这就是幽默自吹自擂的意义所在。所以你提到过，我们有时会隐藏自己的成功，以便显得更热情、更讨人喜欢。因此，当我们认为自己的成就会吓到别人时，我们有时会错误地淡化它们。你说过，如果有人担心自己会显得令人生畏，那么抵消这种影响的方法之一就是强调他们与他人的相似之处。你有一个叫格雷格的朋友，他
exemplifies this strategy. What does Greg do? So Greg Northcraft, co-author of mine, former colleague, long-time professor at the University of Illinois, who is now retired. And what I think Greg does now the most is play a tremendous amount of golf after he moved to California. So he's an incredibly avid golfer and everyone who knows him knows that. In fact, his strategy for showing up as assertive and warm really relied on golf. And what he understood as a psychologist was he understood similarity attraction. The greatest basis of liking an attraction that psychology has ever
完美地诠释了这一策略。格雷格做了什么？格雷格·诺斯克拉夫特，我的合著者、前同事、伊利诺伊大学的资深教授，现在已经退休了。我想格雷格现在做得最多的事情就是搬到加州后打大量的尔夫球。所以他是一个非常狂热的尔夫球手，认识他的人都知道这一点。事实上，他表现得自信又热情的策略真的很依赖高尔夫。作为一个心理学家，他所理解的是相似性吸引。心理学史上记录的对喜爱和吸引的最大基础
documented is similarity. We like people who are like us. And because we think positive things about ourselves, someone who's like us is very likely to get respect because what a brilliant and loving person that person is. So what Greg always told me is, he said, the first thing I always try to do whenever I'm talking to a new person is figure out if there's any chance they like golf. Does that logo on their shirt represent a golf course? I wouldn't know because I don't golf, but Greg did. And if he saw any opportunity to bring golf into the conversation, he would. And he told me a story once about his biggest win, which was talking to somebody else at the university. They didn't know each other, and the subject of the conversation was probably money, but some
就是相似性。我们喜欢和我们相似的人。因为我们对自己的看法很积极，所以像我们这样的人很可能会赢得尊重，因为这个人是多么才华横溢、充满爱心。所以格雷格总是告诉我，他说，我跟新认识的人说话时，总是尝试做的第一件事就是弄清楚他们有没有可能喜欢高尔夫。他衬衫上的那个标志代表高尔夫球场吗？我不知道，因为我不打高尔夫球，但格雷格知道。如果他看到任何把高尔夫球带入对话的机会，他就会这么做。他曾向我讲述过他的一次最大胜利，那就是与大学里的另一个人交谈。他们互不相识，谈话的主题可能是金钱，但有些
scarce resource where you have every reason to think it's gonna be a bit of a territorial battle. But he did something deliberate. He said, I had the status to ask this person to come to my office. Like I had, I was the senior person in this in exchange, but I didn't do that. I specifically offered to go to the other guy's office for one reason only was I wanted to see his physical space. And so I could figure out what does this guy like? What does he do? How could I make a connection with him and He went into the office and he said I couldn't believe my luck I go in and what is behind this guy's desk He tells a story like he's shaking his hand and as he does it he's kind of peering over his shoulder trying to see what's there
稀缺资源，让你有充分的理由认为这会是一场领地之争。但他做了一些深思熟虑的事。他说，我有资格请这个人来我的办公室。就像我拥有一样，我是交流中的资深人士，但我没有那样做。我专门主动去另一个家伙的办公室，原因只有一个，那就是我想看看他的物理空间。这样我才能弄清楚这家伙喜欢什么？他做什么？我如何能与他建立联系？他走进办公室说，我简直不敢相信自己的运气，我走进去，这家伙的办公桌后面是什么？他讲故事的时候就像在跟人握手，当他这么做时，他有点探着身子往肩膀后面看，想看看那里有什么
He says behind the desk. You're not gonna believe it. There's a hole in one trophy He said if you're a golfer and you ever see a hole in one trophy, you're not going to believe it. There's a hole in one trophy. And he said, if you're a golfer and you ever see a hole in one trophy, you know, two things are absolutely true. There has to be a heck of a story behind the trophy. And the person behind the desk is just dying to tell you what it is. So he asks with genuine sincerity and interest, Oh my God, you have a hole in one. You need to tell me this story. And the guy does. And Greg had had one hole in one in his life up until that point. He shares his hole in one, you need to tell me this story." And the guy does. And Greg had had one hole in one in his life up until that point. He shares his hole in one story. And you know exactly how this goes, because we've all been in these situations at times too. Maybe not about golf, but if 60 minutes are
他说，在办公桌后面。你绝对不会相信。有一个一杆进洞奖杯。他说，如果你是个高尔夫球手，你看到过一杆进洞奖杯，你绝对不会相信。这里有一个一杆进洞奖杯。他说，如果你是一个高尔夫球手，如果你看到过一杆进洞奖杯，你知道有两件事是绝对正确的。奖杯背后一定有一个精彩的故事。办公桌后面的人非常渴望告诉你那是什么。于是他以真诚的诚意和兴趣问道：“天哪，你打出了一杆进洞。你得把这个故事讲给我听听。”那个人照做了。到那个时候为止，格雷格一生中只打进过一次一杆进洞。他分享了他的一杆进洞故事。你完全知道这是怎么回事，因为我们也曾身处这些情境中。也许不是关于高尔夫，但如果日历上的会议时间是60分钟
on the calendar for that meeting, 55 minutes are spent talking golf. And by the end, they're friends. And so I always say there's a tremendous amount of luck in that story. He did not know when he walked into the office that day he was going to get an avid golfer. But the part that's not luck is that Greg spent his 30-year career always looking to find genuine points of commonality with people and bringing them up. And that's the, you know, the scientist in him was able to say, I know that that really is how we influence people and how we can build our status. And so the golf had nothing to do
那么55分钟都花在谈论高尔夫上了。到最后，他们成了朋友。所以我总是说那个故事里有很大的运气成分。他那天走进办公室时，并不知道会遇到一个狂热的高尔夫球手。但并非运气的成分在于，格雷格在他30年的职业生涯中，一直在寻找与人们真正的共同点并把它们提出来。这就是，你知道的，他身上的科学家特质能够让他说，我知道这确实是我们影响他人以及如何建立地位的方式。所以高尔夫与他们要讨论的任何金钱问题都毫无关系
with whatever money discussion they were gonna have, but it built that rapport. And that's the part where we could be more intentional about saying to somebody, like, I see you and we have something in common, and that is an easy tool we can all use, start to build the relationship and build status. So your point here, Alison, is that in some ways, maybe if you're a woman, maybe if you're
但它建立了这种融洽的关系。这就是我们可以更有意识地对某人说：“我看到你了，我们有共同点”，这是一个我们可以用来开始建立关系和地位的简单工具。所以艾莉森，你的观点是，在某些方面，也许如果你是一名女性，也许如果你是一个
a person of color, maybe if you're an elderly person, you might be seen as different from the get-go. And so the importance of finding similarities in some ways becomes more important because you actually want to show the other person you have a point of connection. There's an element of this that also sounds really unfair because you're asking the person who is being unfairly perceived as being different, different because she's a woman, different because you're old, different because of something that's outside of your own power to change. You're asking them to do the heavy lifting
有色人种，也许如果你是一个老年人，你从一开始就可能会被视为与众不同。因此，在某些方面，寻找相似之处的重要性变得更加重要，因为你实际上想向对方展示你们有连接点。这里还有一个让人觉得非常不公平的因素，因为你在要求那个被不公平地视作不同的人去做沉重的负担，因为她是女性而不同，因为你老了而不同，因为一些你无法控制的事情而不同。你要求他们承担繁重的工作
and the hard work to establish similarity in some ways to compensate for the stereotypes that might be in the mind of the other person. Yeah, thank you for asking that. Because something I think about in my work a lot, because I do spend a lot of time counseling women and helping them excel, essentially figuring out how to take the rules of an unfair game and succeed anyway. And so I admit there's many things in all of this that are
和艰苦的工作来建立相似性，在某种程度上是为了弥补可能存在于对方心中的刻板印象。是的，谢谢你问这个问题。因为这是我在工作中经常思考的事情，因为我确实花了很多时间为女性提供咨询并帮助她们脱颖而出，本质上是弄清楚如何利用不公平游戏的规则，无论如何都要取得成功。所以我承认，这一切当中有很多事情是
incredibly unfair. But I look at Greg's example, right? Human beings like people who are like them. That's not a standard that only applies to women, people of color, somebody who lacks an ascribed status characteristic. Greg is a white man. He still benefited tremendously in his career from establishing real relationships that started by people saying, we have something really in common. But what he did was he went looking for it. So one of the ways that I feel really good about working with women in particular and counseling them on things they can do is that I would give the exact same advice to everybody because these are the things we see in psychology are the good things. The humor bragging as an example, it could be a great tool to overcome a status disadvantage
极其不公平的。但我看到了格雷格的例子，对吧？人类喜欢和自己相似的人。这不是一个只适用于女性、有色人种或缺乏归属地位特征的人的标准。格雷格是一个白人。他在职业生涯中仍然通过建立真正的人际关系获得了巨大的好处，这些关系始于人们说，我们有真正的共同点。但他所做的就是去寻找它。因此，我特别乐于与女性合作并就她们可以做的事情向她们提供咨询的原因之一是，我会给每个人完全相同的建议，因为这些都是我们在心理学中看到的好的事情。以幽默自吹自擂为例，它可以成为克服地位劣势的绝佳工具
that you don't deserve, but it's just as good if you already were born with a status privilege. So the same science and solutions are universal and they apply to everybody. It's just that people who have been handed disadvantage that they don't deserve could really benefit from them. So Alison, in 2021, the former Georgia State Representative Stacey Abrams was on CBS Sunday morning when she was asked the question, do you want to be president? Now this was a very tricky question for her. She had just lost her bid for governor a couple of years before. So it might have been seen as overly ambitious to answer yes.
你并不罪有应得，但如果你生来就享有地位特权，它也同样好。所以同样的科学和解决方案是通用的，它们适用于每个人。只是那些被赋予了他们不应承受的劣势的人可以从中真正受益。艾莉森，在2021年，前佐治亚州州众议员斯泰西·阿布拉姆斯在CBS周日早间节目中被问到一个问题：你想成为总统吗？现在这对她来说是一个非常棘手的问题。几年前她刚刚输掉了州长竞选。所以如果回答“是”可能会被视为过于雄心勃勃。
And her critics might have even said it would be delusional. I want to play you a clip of her response. have even said it would be delusional. I want to play you a clip of her response. Do I hold it as an ambition? Absolutely. And even more importantly, when someone asks me if that's my ambition, I have a responsibility to say yes for every young woman, every person of color, every young person of color who sees me and decides what they're capable of based on what I think I'm capable of. So, Alison, you say that this response is a masterclass
她的批评者甚至可能会说这是妄想。我想放一段她的回应片段。甚至可能会说这是妄想。我想放一段她的回应片段。我把它当作一种雄心吗？当然。更重要的是，当有人问我这是否是我的雄心时，我有责任说是，为了每一个年轻女性，每一个有色人种，每一个看到我并根据我认为自己有能力做到的事情来决定他们自己有能力做到的年轻有色人种。所以，艾莉森，你说这个回应是一个大师级的教程
in how to think about warmth and assertiveness. How so? So she's asked a direct question. And in situations like this, many people might feel like they wanna deflect. They don't wanna self-promote. They don't wanna come across as being overly ambitious or self aggrandizing. But she essentially has a two sentence response. It is not long, but the first sentence hits on assertiveness and the second sentence hits on
关于如何思考热情和自信。怎么说呢？所以有人直接问了她一个问题。在这种情况下，许多人可能会觉得他们想回避。他们不想自我推销。他们不想显得过于雄心勃勃或自命不凡。但她基本上有一个两句话的回应。它不长，但第一句话击中了自信，第二句话击中了
warmth. Is this my ambition to be the president of the United States? Absolutely. Sounds pretty assertive. The second one, I have a responsibility to answer that question because I'm a role model for other people. And in that, she is saying I care about other people. So what I think about this that is brilliant is that she didn't lead with this information. She was asked a question, but when she had an opportunity
热情。这是我想成为美国总统的雄心吗？当然。听起来挺自信的。第二句，我有责任回答这个问题，因为我是其他人的榜样。在这一点上，她说我关心其他人。所以我认为这很棒的地方在于，她没有用这些信息主导。她被问了一个问题，但当她有机会
to put something out into the world that originated with her, she had a two sentence response that put out, I am assertive and I am warm. People like Stacey, I've become more aware of thinking about at any given moment there are multiple truths. And what's my goal in this interaction? You may not want to run for the president of the United States. You may never end up on a CBS national show, but you get a million opportunities
把源自她自己的东西推向世界时，她有一个两句话的回应，传达出：我很自信，我很热情。像斯泰西这样的人，我变得更加意识到在任何特定时刻都存在多种真理。我在这次互动中的目标是什么？你可能不想竞选美国总统。你可能永远也不会登上CBS全国节目，但你拥有一百万次机会
to be interviewed every single day. Every time someone says, how are you? How's work? What's up? Those are opportunities to tell a story. And I think what's a good example of what she did is someone gave her an opportunity and she didn't waste it. Alison Fregale is an organizational psychologist at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill. She's the author of Likeable Badass, How Women Get the Success They Deserve. Allison, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It is such a pleasure. So happy to be here. HIDDEN BRAIN is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
每天都被采访。每次有人说，你好吗？工作怎么样？怎么了？这些都是讲故事的机会。我认为她所做的一个很好的例子是，有人给了她一个机会，而她没有浪费它。艾莉森·弗雷盖尔是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的组织心理学家。她是《讨人喜欢的女硬汉：女性如何获得应得的成功》一书的作者。艾莉森，非常感谢你今天加入“隐形大脑”。这真是太高兴了。非常高兴来到这里。“隐形大脑”由隐形大脑传媒制作。
Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. We end today with a story from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. This My Unsung Hero segment is brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. Today's story comes from Molly Baker. In March of 2018, Molly lost her husband Marlin in a skiing accident. In the first few weeks after his death, her community provided a lot of support,
我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是隐形大脑的执行编辑。最后，我们以来自我们姐妹播客《无名英雄》的一个故事结束今天的节目。本期《无名英雄》由T-Mobile企业版赞助播出。今天的故事来自莫莉·贝克。2018年3月，莫莉在一次滑雪事故中失去了丈夫马林。在他去世后的头几周里，她的社区提供了大量的支持，
but after a while, the cards and meals started to slow down. People have, you know, families come into town and families left, people have to get back to their jobs, people have to get back to their normal life, and so things kind of drop off. I had a dear friend of mine, Carla Vale, who came up with this idea that maybe she could set up a calendar of sorts that would assign people a particular day.
但过了一会儿，卡片和饭菜开始减少了。人们，你知道的，家属来到了镇上，家属又离开了，人们必须回去工作，人们必须回到正常的生活中，所以事情有点减少了。我有一个亲爱的朋友卡拉·韦尔，她想出了一个主意，也许她可以建立某种日历，给每个人分配一个特定的日子。
And what that looked like for them was that on that day, they would reach out to me in some tangible way, maybe via text, maybe a phone call, maybe a card, they would drop off a card, maybe they would drop some chocolates or something off of my door. It didn't have to be anything big. And then also for me, I could look at the calendar. I was given the names, and so I could look at the calendar and be like,
对他们来说，这意味着在那一天，他们会以某种切实的方式联系我，也许是通过短信，也许是一个电话，也许是一张卡片，他们会送来一张卡片，也许他们会把一些巧克力或其他东西放在我的门上。不需要是什么大事。然后对我来说，我也可以查看日历。我得到了名字，所以我可以查看日历并像这样：
oh, it's the sixth today and so-and-so's assigned. And I could reach out to them as well if I needed some emotional support or just needed something. Like maybe I needed them to run an errand for me, or if that was possible. So it worked both ways. A lot of people are really, really uncomfortable around grief and loss and so what they do is instead of doing something they just do nothing and they don't say anything and that's the worst. I mean I remember going to the
哦，今天是第六天，某某被分配了。如果我需要一些情感支持或者只是需要什么东西，我也可以联系他们。就像我可能需要他们为我跑腿一样，如果可能的话。所以这是双向的。很多人对悲伤和失落感到非常非常不舒服，所以他们不是做点什么，而是什么都不做，什么也不说，那是绝对最糟糕的。我的意思是，我记得去
grocery store and I would see someone the distance they would know me and they would literally turn around and walk the other direction because they were so uncomfortable. They were so uncomfortable with my loss that they didn't know what to say to me. So that's why it was nice to have that Cow and Girls set up so that that was tangible, like, oh, you could send a text, you could do this, you could do that. Some ideas of tangible ways was very helpful. I love that Carla did this,
杂货店，我会看到远处有人，他们认识我，他们会 literalmente 转过身往另一个方向走，因为他们太不舒服了。他们对我的失去感到如此不舒服，以至于他们不知道该对我说什么。这就是为什么很高兴能建立那个日历安排，这样就是切实的，比如，你可以发短信，你可以做这个，你可以做那个。提供切实方法的建议非常有帮助。我很高兴卡拉做了这件事，
and it was a way that she was able to use her unique gifts to help other people love on me. And I will always be grateful, forever grateful for that year in my life. Molly Baker lives in Sammamish, Washington. This segment of My Unsung Hero was brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. If you love the ideas that we feature on Hidden Brain and you'd like to help support our work, please consider signing up for our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. It's where you'll find conversations you won't hear anywhere else, like our segment, Your Questions Answered.
这是一种她能够利用自己独特的才能来帮助其他人爱护我的方式。我将永远感激，永远感激我生命中的那一年。莫莉·贝克住在华盛顿州萨马米什。本期《无名英雄》由T-Mobile企业版赞助播出。如果你喜欢我们在“隐形大脑”中推崇的理念，并且想帮助支持我们的工作，请考虑注册我们的播客订阅“隐形大脑+”。在那里你会找到你在其他任何地方都听不到的对话，比如我们的栏目“你的问题得到了解答”。
And your membership in Hidden Brain Plus helps to fund the many hours of research, writing, and production that we put into every episode of the show. You can sign up for Hidden Brain Plus by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you have Apple devices or listen on Apple podcasts, you can also find HiddenBrain by going to apple.co.uk.
你在“隐形大脑+”上的会员资格有助于资助我们为节目的每一集投入的大量研究、写作和制作时间。你可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 注册“隐形大脑+”。如果你有苹果设备或在苹果播客上收听，你也可以通过访问 apple.co.uk 找到“隐形大脑”。
We truly appreciate your support. I'm Shankar V. Dantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们非常感谢您的支持。我是尚卡尔·V·丹坦。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。